hey this is preshtalwalka reminding you
to mind your decisions
start with a small square and then draw
a large square so that one vertex of the
large square passes through the midpoint
of the small square side as shown in the
diagram
now shade this triangle in red and shade
this rectangle in red
what fraction of the total area is
shaded in red
i saw this problem on twitter and many
people had fun with it
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
since we're only interested in the
fraction of the total area that's in red
we can simplify matters by labeling this
length as one
that means this length will also be
equal to one and the entire small square
side will have a length of two
this will also be equal to two
we can then use the pythagorean theorem
to solve that the hypotenuse of this
one-two triangle will be equal to the
square root of five
notice this will be the length of the
larger square side
now we're going to consider some similar
triangles
this blue triangle will be similar to
the red triangle
therefore the smaller leg has to be half
the length of the larger leg
so this will be a length of 0.5
furthermore we have another similar
triangle
this triangle right here
if we label the longer leg as a
then we have a divided by 2 has to be
the same ratio as in this triangle here
which is equal to 2 divided by the
square root 5.
we simplify this and we get that a is
equal to 4 divided by the square root of
5.
as a result we can solve that this
length here will be the square root of 5
minus 4 over the square root of 5 which
simplifies to be 1 over the square root
of 5.
we have all the necessary lengths to
solve this problem
the red area will be the sum of two
shapes it'll be the area of this which
is one half of one times point five
then we have the area of this rectangle
which will be the square root of five
multiplied by one over the square root
of five
this all simplifies to be 1.25
we now want to calculate the total area
so we'll do that by calculating the area
of the large square
this will be the square root of 5
squared
we then want the area of this triangle
which will be 1 times 0.5 all over 2
and then we have the area of this
triangle which is 1 times 2 all over 2.
this all simplifies to be 6.25
we now take the area of the red shapes
divided by the total area and we get
1.25 divided by 6.25 and that simplifies
to be one over five i'm sure there are
many other ways to solve this problem
let people know in the comments which
way you solved it
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you